my name is carl smartey i'm a former
drug kingpin and i ran a multi-million
dollar drug business which led me to six
years in prison and i'm about to play
never have i ever
when you're in the drug game happened
multiple times where i've been robbed
guns pointed there was one particular
time where like one of my guys like
stepped out of the stash house and they
came in you know with a gun pointed at
his head they tied everybody up which is
crazy to me they they stole all the weed
and a little bit of money from the safe
but there was so much coke on the table
that they didn't realize it was coke and
they left it
there so we you know they stole like
maybe five grand of weed and left like a
hundred thousand dollars worth of coke
on the table
when i was younger i was cutting my work
but i quickly found out the the better
way to like be an honest drug dealer is
not to cut your work and that's how you
have people come back is the same thing
with the business world if you deliver a
great product you'll still have that
consistency of clientele
crazy true story it was a drought which
means like there was not a lot of stuff
coming in and so i had to go up to a
second supply that i had in washington
heights i went up to this guy bought a
kilo off of him when i got home i like
left it on the table and i stepped out i
came back and it was melted
like liquid melted and so i'm with my
boy joey and we're like yo what the
we're gonna do right now like we just
spent like
35 000 on this key he was like yo you
got to call this guy back you got to
call this guy back and so i i was like
he's going to be like yo he i'm playing
him he's playing me you know there's
going to be a
conflict i grabbed like the liquid
yellow plastic bag and i went all the
way uptown
and brought it to her and i was like yo
this is just you sold me
and he was like uh cool and so
he gave me my money back and that was it
you know
[Music]
at the d.a like ran on me they they had
a warrant for the house that that i had
all the stash drugs at uh they caught me
coming out of the house they took my car
the bmw m3 they were driving that and
then they stuck me in this uh like dodge
caravan and i was there with one officer
sat with him and i'm like yo can you
just let me like give you some money and
uh you know you can stash the rest of
the money blah blah blah because he had
access to like the money that they
caught and i was like yo just take like
five grand and just leave the rest you
know what i mean and he was like yo you
really trying to bribe me right now and
i'm like nah nah nah but you know what i
mean please and uh
and i was like you know never mind
so
yeah i tried but it didn't work
[Music]
we didn't call it toilet wine we called
the hooch so i actually made like five
gallons a week and i was selling five
dollar cups um to other inmates i would
get these like large gallons through the
laundry room so we had like the
detergent that would finish i'll stash
all those bottles families in new york
state you could bring like packages up
to your loved ones once a month so i
would ask them to send me like grapes
grapefruit and just rot all the fruit in
these bottles and then i'll take like 10
kool-aid oil stuff and then i'll steal
like the coffee filters from the staff
that was working in the library so i'll
take those coffee filters take bread and
that'll be my yeast and i'll mold the
bread all together and i'll stick it
into the coffee filter
wrap it up and then i'm sticking it in
the bottle and so it'll ferment
and so you'll take that bottle and
you'll you'll you'll open it up little
by little to gas it out because if you
don't gas it out it'll just blow up like
a volcano and i've had that happen
before and it's not pretty and it stinks
um and so basically like your toilet is
refrigerator because it's like a metal
toilet and
but yeah that's how i did it and you
make like
you can make it in eight days and it'll
taste like wine
[Music]
i've witnessed multiple people
overdosing unfortunately off of drugs
that i've sold uh not proud of it um you
know and it's it's sad you know and and
that's what like made me regret all the
things that i was doing back in the day
um you know even neighbors that i've
seen like that i sold coke to or heroin
to back in the day i would see them
you know pass out in od um i was
when i when i was younger i was selling
uh crack out of like crack houses so
i'll see that happening all the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
yeah i'm considering and selling
legalized marijuana again i'm starting a
company called con bud i'm working and
talking to like legislators and and
trying to be part of that legacy group
that was affected by the drug industry
you know and trying to take advantage of
like opening up a space where i also
have the same similar mission
hiring people training people and
apprenticeship program where we teach
people how to you know run a business
and sell
legal marijuana again
[Music]
[Music]
you